vous l'avez dit mais c'est plat trêve
vous respecter la décision de justice
mais vous avez un avis la concernant
alors vous avez développé plusieurs
points le premier c'est une ingérence un
de l'autorité administrative dans la
gestion des collectivités locales
communales qui si elle devait s'étendre
serait un vrai problème ce sera un
problème on regarde un principe
constitutionnel qui est un principe de
libre administration des collectivités
territoriales
c'est à dire que depuis toujours le juge
constitutionnel a reconnu et le juge
administratif avec lui que les
collectivités s'administrent librement
en l'occurrence le conseil municipal de
chalon a pris une décision souveraine
qui a été motivée par un certain nombre
de principes et notamment évidemment
celui de laïcité et de neutralité des
fonctionnement des services publics
ce que le juge administratif nous dit
c'est que ces principes ne serait pas
suffisant qu'il faudrait des conditions
supplémentaires et draconiennes pour
pouvoir modifier l'organisation d'un
service public donc là c'est en
l'occurrence sur cette décision
s'agissant des cantines scolaires mais
demain si on suit ce raisonnement si on
met à chaque modification du service
public des conditions draconiennes
on finira par avoir des collectivités
qui n'oseront pas sous peine d'être
renvoyés en justice
modifier le moindre aspect de leur
service public or c'est notre
responsabilité des toujours dans
l'adaptation
donc oui se considérant du juge de lyon
nous pose souci parce qu'il nous paraît
porter atteinte à la libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales
et puis sur le fait le le fait lui-même
un vous avez évoqué ce ce que vous
appelez un fichage des familles dont la
justice administrative n'a pas tenu
compte c'est sa goût dit
c'est la grande interrogation de ce
jugement c'était d'ailleurs la grande
interrogation de l'audience puisque le
rapporteur public lui-même avait dit que
le fichage n'était pas établie or je
rappelle parce que c'est à la base de la
décision qui a été prise au printemps
2015 qu' on ne peut pas organiser un
service de plat de substitution dans les
cantines
lorsque du port est servi si on a pas le
nom exact des enfants concernés ne
serait ce que pour les commandes par
exemple et pour savoir à qui on donne
ses plats donc ça veut dire concrètement
que sans fichage et c'était bien ce qui
se passait à chalon sur saône depuis des
décennies on fichait les familles
elle remplissait une case au début
d'année scolaire un petit peu en amont
au printemps pour la rentrée qui suivait
en cochant avec ou sans porc et bien ce
fichage à nos yeux c'est un fichage
religieux puisqu'il est il est
conditionné par un interdit religieux
pour nous ça n'est pas conforme à la loi
mais ce qui nous surprend et c'est pour
ça qu'on va interroger le conseil d'état
c'est que le juge de lyon n'en tiennent
absolument pas compte parce que si l'on
tient compte en réalité il est obligé de
reconnaître que ce fichage ne peut pas
durer
et c'est là où l'enjeu dépasse chalon
sur saône parce que partout en france
lorsque vous avez des plats de
substitution à part quand vous avez des
self où vous avez le double de repas
pour tous les enfants
nous on a fait le calcul ces deux
millions d'euros d'installer des serbes
dans toutes les écoles et ça n'est pas
possible pour les enfants de maternelle
qui peuvent pas servir tout ça donc il
faudra quand même un fichage pour ces
enfants là mais en tout état de cause
dans toutes les écoles où vous avez un
fichage pour servir des plastiques
titution si jamais on reconnaît que ce
fichage comme nous l'estimons est
illégale alors toutes les décisions dans
toutes les communes peuvent être
attaquable donc on sent que le juge a
reculé devant l'effort et s'il avait
reconnu l'existence fichage ils étaient
obligés de nous suivre
il ne la reconnaît pas nous demanderons
donc au conseil d'état de la reconnaître
donc c'était ma dernière question la
prochaine étape pour vous c et conseil
d'état et conseil constitutionnel 1
concernant plutôt le jugement de dijon
c'est ça c'est à dire que conseil d'état
parce que nous allons demander au
conseil d'état de casser la décision du
juge administratif de lyon qui ne nous
paraît pas conforme au droit encore une
fois je le dis avec beaucoup de respect
pour la personne du juge mais c'est un
vrai combat philosophie qui nous semble
que la philosophie ici n'est pas
conforme à la lettre de la loi de 1905
et la grande loi sur la laïcité en
france
et puis d'autres principes
constitutionnels en particulier mais
nous allons également saisir le conseil
constitutionnel
parce que le juge de dijon qui a mis
très longtemps à juger alors qu'il nous
avait dit que dans le trimestre tout
serait réglé il a fallu attendre deux
ans a consulté des autorités
administratives indépendantes
le défenseur des droits la commission
nationale de défense des droits de
l'homme qui sont en partie composée de
magistrats de l'ordre administratif qui
ont rendu un quasi jugement sur lequel
il s'est appuyé et il a d'ailleurs été
cassée par le juge d'appel de lyon donc
il nous semble que là il n'y a pas un
bon fonctionnement l'officier
administrative on a droit de demander un
avis on n'a pas le droit de recevoir un
oukase un quasi prêt jugement
donc ça ça mérite qu'on fasse changer la
loi et c'est le conseil constitutionnel
qui ont saisi rats % entendu merci